[ MUSIC ]
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WE'RE COMING TO YOU THIS
THURSDAY UNFORTUNATELY FROM A
VERY SICK CITY, A PLACE WHERE
MANY OF THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
AREN'T JUST WRONG BUT
INCREASINGLY ARE IRRATIONAL.
WASHINGTON IS IN THE GRIP OF
UNPRECEDENTED MASS HYSTERIA OVER
RUSSIA.
YES, RUSSIA.
TAKE THREE STEPS BACK.
IT'S A FREEZING, POOR COUNTRY ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE GLOBE
WHERE THE AVERAGE LIFE
EXPECTANCY IS LOWER THAN THAT IN
BANGLADESH.
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY IS SMALL HE
WERE THE ECONOMY OF TEXAS.
IT'S A COUNTRY THAT COULD BARELY
PRODUCE A WORKING ESCALATOR OR
NONPOISONING VODKA.
IT'S SAD AND INCREASINGLY
IRRELEVANT IS ACCORDING TO
DEMOCRATS IN WASHINGTON IN
VIRTUALLY COMPLETE CONTROL OF
THE WORKINGS OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
THEY TELL US THAT EVERY DAY AND
THEY'RE STARTING TO SEEM LIKE
THEY BELIEVE IT.
THAT'S DEMENTED.
MOST STRIKING EXAMPLE COMES FROM
FORMER DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JIM CLAPPER.
IN AN INTERVIEW YESTERDAY,
CLAPPER SAID THAT RUSSIA FLIPPED
TO THE RESULTS OF THE 2016
ELECTION, GOT TRUMP ELECTED OVER
HILLARY.
AS FOR EVIDENCE OF THAT, CLAPPER
ADMITTED HE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
BECAUSE, OF COURSE, HE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY!
NO ONE ELSE HAS ANY EITHER!
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT ANY
FOREIGN COUNTRY CHANGED A SINGLE
AMERICAN VOTE IN 2016.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS CLAPPER'S
POSITION JUST TWO YEARS AGO WHEN
IT WAS THE POSITION OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION THAT VOTE
TAMPERING BY A FOREIGN POWER WAS
COMPLETELY IRRESPONSIBLE AND
IMPOSSIBLE TO CONTEMPLATE.
NOW THAT TRUMP IS IN OFFICE, OF
COURSE, CLAPPER AND OTHER
DEMOCRATS ARE WARNING THAT
RUSSIA WILL TRY TO SUBVERT THIS
YEAR'S MIDTERM AS WELL.
THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF THAT
EITHER.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND THAT JIM
CLAPPER IS NOT SOME FRINGE RADIO
SHOW HOST OR BACK BENCHER IN
CONGRESS.
FOR YEARS, HE HELD ONE OF THE
TOP INTELLIGENCE POSTS IN THE
COUNTRY, YET HE'S DELUSIONAL.
THAT'S TERRIFYING.
AND HE'S NOT THE ONLY
DELUSIONSNAL ONE.
THE CIA OPERATIVES SPYING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN SOUND LIKE HE'S
UNBALANCED.
REPORT TODAY FROM THE DAILY
CALLER FINDS THAT THAT MAN
ONCELY ACCUSED A RUSSIAN
ACADEMIC IN CAMBRIDGE UNIVERSITY
OF BEING A RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE.
THIS AFTERNOON, CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS RECEIVED A CLASSIFIED
BRIEFING FROM DOJ AND INTEL
OFFICIALS ABOUT ACTUAL SPYING
THAT TOOK PLACE IN 2016, NOT
SPYING FROM SPOOKY RUSSIAN
AGENTS SENT FROM THE KREMLIN BUT
FROM THE OBAMA F.B.I.
THAT MIGHT PUT SOME OF THIS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US NOW.
I NIGHT START WITH AN IMMEDIATE
QUESTION BUT IT DETERMINES HOW
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS STORY,
WHAT THEY READ AND SEE ON
TELEVISION.
THERE'S STILL NEWS OUTLETS AS OF
TONIGHT THAT ARE PRETENDING LIKE
THERE WAS NO SPYING ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
CAN YOU JUST SAY DEFINITIVELY,
DO WE KNOW AS A FACTUAL MATTER
THAT THE OBAMA F.B.I. SPIED ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, OR DON'T WE?
>> EVERYONE KNOWS THERE WAS A
SPY AND IN FACT PEOPLE WHO WERE
INVOLVED IN THE SPYING ARE
ADMITTING THERE WAS A SPY.
THEY'RE SAYING, THOUGH, BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT TERM IS "HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE INFORMANT" OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT
THEREFORE IT'S NOT A SPY WHEREAS
NORMAL AMERICANS UNDERSTAND WHEN
YOU'RE GATHERING INFORMATION ON
SOMEONE SURREPTITIOUSLY, THAT'S
THE COMMON DEFINITION OF SPYING.
MORE THAN THAT, THAT'S JUST A
STUNNING REVELATION THIS IS
HAPPENING UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT THERE WOULD
BE THIS KIND OF SURVEILLANCE,
NOT JUST AT LEAST ONE HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE INFORMANT BUT ALSO
WIRE TAPS, NATIONAL SECURITY
LETTERS WHICH IS HOW COULD YOU
SECRETLY GET A SUBPOENA AND WHO
KNOWS WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON?
ACTUALLY LIKE WIDESPREAD SPYING
INVOLVING MULTIPLE PEOPLE IN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND WE STILL
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGHT --
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE POINT.
I SHOULD POINT OUT IN THE
INTEREST OF HONESTY THESE ARE
AGENCIES CONTROLLED BY THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME AT ALL WHY
WE DON'T KNOW THIS AND WHY THE
COMMITTEES IN CONGRESS WHO HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER ALL THIS DON'T
KNOW.
THERE WAS A MEETING TODAY
FAMOUSLY ABOUT THIS, TOM.
DO YOU THINK MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WILL GET CHARMED OF OVERSIGHT OF
THIS STUFF KNOW THE ANSWER AS OF
TONIGHT?
>> THEY'RE BEING STRUNG ALONG.
THIS MEETING WAS FOR SHOW.
WE WANT TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULD THEY BE
STRUNG ALONG?
>> THESE AGENCIES HAVE CONTEMPT
FOR CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
YOU HAVE THIS EXTRAORDINARY
SITUATION OF A
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND F.B.I. ATTACKING
AND UNDERMINING THE
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT
ACTIVITIES OF A
REPUBLICAN-CONTROLLED HOUSE AND
SENATE, AND THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
TURN OVER THE DOCUMENTS, SO SOON
WE'LL HAVE A MEETING.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE SECRET SPY
GAME WE HAD, BUT IT WON'T BE
PUBLIC.
WE WON'T TELL YOU WHAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF TURNING OVER
DOCUMENTS, WHICH IS STILL THE
BIG FIGHT.
NOW, JUDICIAL WATCH SPECIAL EYES
AND FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT,
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THE
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS REALLY TELL
WHAT YOU WENT ON, AND GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL DESCRIPTIONS OF WHAT
WENT ON AS WE'RE LEARNING FROM
THE OBAMA GANG THAT IS
DESCRIBING THIS SPY AS AN
INFORMANT AND IN A DISHONEST
WAY, WE NEED TO SEE THE
DOCUMENTS.
WE NEED TO KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
WAS THIS PERSON PAID?
WAS MONEY TRANSFERRED AS A
RESULT OF HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
WHO ELSE WAS HE WORKING WITH?
WERE THERE OTHERS?
>> Tucker: THERE'S A TIME
LIMIT HERE.
SAND IS PASSING THROUGH THE HOUR
GLASS HERE.
IF DEMOCRATS TAKE THE HOUSE AND
TAKE MAJORITY CONTROL OF THESE
COMMITTEES, THEN HOW WILL WE
FIND OUT?
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN GETTING
THIS INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC.
>> THAT'S WHY IT'LL BE NICE IF
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT SPYING IS NOT
GOOD FOR HAVING AMERICANS HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE F.B.I.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU HEARD
LIBERALS SAY THAT?
>> THERE'S BEEN A FEW,
EXCEEDINGLY FEW.
MARK PENN IS ONE THAT'S BEEN
MAKING THAT ARGUMENT.
IN ADDITION THAT THE -- IS
ACCOUNTABLE TO NO ONE, I THINK
IT MUST MEAN THE INFORMATION IS
REALLY DAMAGING, REALLY
DANGEROUS, BUT THEY'RE WILLING
TO SUBVERT ANY AUTHORITY IN
ORDER TO KEEP THAT A SECRET.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK
THEY THINK THEY CAN KEEP THIS
FROM GETTING OUT.
I DON'T THINK THEY WILL ACTUALLY
DO THAT.
>> Tucker: IN THE PRETEXT THEY
USED TO HIDE THIS INFORMATION
FROM PUBLIC VIEW ARE DISHONEST.
TONIGHT, REPORTER IN WASHINGTON
HAS A PIECE EXPLAINING THAT ONE
OF THE MANY FACTS REDACTED BY
THE F.B.I. IN DOCUMENTSA
OBTAINED THROUGH FOYA REVEALS
ANDY MCCABE SPENT $70,000 ON A
PIECE OF OFFICE FURNITURE.
THEY HELD THAT BACK ON GROUNDS
OF NATIONAL SECURITY.
DOES THAT IMPERIL US, TOM, AS A
COUNTRY NOW THAT OUR ENEMIES
KNOW THAT ANDY MCCABE SPENT
$70,000 ON A PIECE OF OFFICE
FURNITURE?
>> OF COURSE IT DOESN'T IT SHOWS
YOU THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE CAN'T BE TRUSTED TO
EVALUATE FAIRLY WHETHER
DOCUMENTS SHOULD BE RELEASED OR
NOT.
AND THE PRESIDENT WHO
CONSTITUTIONALLY RUNS THE
AGENCIES NEEDS INTERVENE AND
STOP BEING -- AND STOP HIMSELF
FROM BEING STRUNG ALONG BY HIS
APPOINTEES AND TELL THEM TO
RELEASE THESE RECORDS.
REVIEW THEM QUICKLY.
>> Tucker: NEVER LISTEN TO
YOUR LAWYERS.
IF THERE'S ONE PIECE OF ADVICE I
HAVE FOR MY CHILDREN IS DON'T
LISTEN TO YOUR LAWYERS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE TRUTH AT